James: Hi YouTube, I viewed your video and
I think I understand your concerns in respect
to the affect of knowledge based regulation
of markets.
As you know on the budget this week we made
clear our intention to proceed with a common
securities regulator in Canada.
That will help us with both parts of the capital
market that are not yet regulated in the uniform
way across Canada.
One of the lessons of the financial crisis
certainly is that all market participants,
and that all market products need to be tracked.
We need to have a knowledge based assessment.
And we need to protect consumers in that way.
So we have a good regulatory system with respect
to our life insurance companies and our banks
through the office of the superintendants
of national institutions which reports to
the people of Canada through me as minister
of finance.
And we have the other regulatory tools that
we use regularly on a federal basis.
That has put us in good shape.
We are in the best shape of I daresay any
financial system in the world right now.
And that's certainly what I'm hearing at Davos.
But we need to be more on the capital market
side which we will with a national securities
regulator.